you and Aquaman getting a fight who's
coming out on top oh dude the ocean's
going to have a new ruler it's going to
be in green I think you know the answer
to that one the guy who has sharks bre I
think you like your chances against
Aquaman a amateurs we're here at La
ComiCon asking folks on the street are
you going to check out the new Aquaman
[Music]
movie nope not seeing that one I'm not
nothing think it either I will yep we
are Jason Mamoa yeah because of Jason
Mamoa all right and will you be
accompanying her absolutely sure you
sound pumped about do you even know what
the subtitle is the subtitle no yeah
it's it's the lost kingdom and uh and we
got to find it I'm going to find it
apparently cuz I need to find it I think
so yeah all right how about you excited
for Aquaman too I mean a little bit I
thought the first one was pretty good so
I don't know I'm very intrigued to see
where this leads off afterwards there's
a lot of roughing to do with the DC
films I got to get props to Jason mamoy
and James won so hopefully it's good but
it's not I'm not losing sleep over it at
first I was not on board but this new
trailer it actually really hooked me I'm
so much more psyched than I ever thought
I would be I I think it's going to be a
lot better than everyone thinks and I'm
really hoping it is a man honestly I'm
going to wait for it to come on the
streaming services all right wow I guess
we're waiting I mean she spoke I guess
we're waiting for it to come out on the
streaming I didn't need to ask you did I
no you didn't even need to ask me at
that
[Music]
point that's going to be Superman of
course Batman Batman I've always been
partial to Batman DCU specifically uh
Wonder Woman they ever hook up felt like
they should have been a thing for a
little while she can't stay with Batman
he's just too boring right she's too
boring no he's too boring did you see
the look that Haley gave me when she
thought I said Wonder Woman was too
boring honestly Wonder Woman she still
Takes the Cake for me you're not going
to you won't believe my answer I think
Harley Quinn I'll give you Harley Quinn
I like what marar Robie has been able to
do with the character and yet each
interpretation is valid and makes sense
in my opinion superhero I'm going to go
with Shazam all right and you favorite
DC Superhero it sounds really generic to
say Batman but I just I love I love
Batman it sounds really generic and it
sounds really correct you think Shazam
could take Batman I mean yes good yeah
good you're really on top of this
[Music]
stuff absolutely oh for sure for sure
he's the guy for it yeah he's he's an
interesting filmmaker so he'll he'll
spice it up a little bit I'm excited cuz
I really like what he did with Gardians
of the Galaxy and I think he can bring a
good structure that the DCU really needs
right now to be honest not so much I
love the DCU as it is I wish they could
continue the franchise I'm pretty
excited I don't know what to expect you
never do really I liked where things
were going originally but that's getting
into our territory that we don't have
time for but if you're listening DCU
people that stuff was great H to the
king to the king Hail to the King J Jes
gun is going to inject some fresh life
into the world of DC with his DCU so
what actor do we need to get in on the
ground floor elevator yeah I know they
have guy Gardener already ready for uh
James gun's new Superman can we bring
Ryan Reynolds back or do you just want
to forget about that no let's let him do
Deadpool and Marvel let's not I don't
even want to see him back in a Green
Lantern suit if anyone's watching out
there James gun please cast Jensen
Ackles as Batman please please please do
it uh Henry caval okay I'm going to say
an answer is going to make your audience
mad I stand by B
he was the best Bruce Wayne there has
ever been and we need to get him back in
there as Batman you can build it around
him Ben Affleck if he's available if
he's not currently in line at a Duncan
maybe he takes you up on that probably
uh Leonardo DiCaprio is some villain
shamik Moore EST static okay so we get
shamik Moore who maybe borrow from the
Spider-Man franchise the exaggerated
Swagger of a black team yeah yeah I want
somebody who isn't so mainstream they
need some fresh faces some fresh blood
for sure I think it would be good to
have some unknowns come in and some
fresh blood people that we that aren't
famous yet I think would be the best
option we're tired of a-listers if
you're on a list we don't want you in
the DCU we want some fresh faces you
know I'd like to see Ringo as Lex Luthor
you know it'd be great you know have to
shave all his beautiful hair off all
right well he's got a little bit left I
suppose I think we should get molik
culan in there why not get mcau caulin
in the DCU get him in there why not I
mean look he foiled two adults when he
was a little kid imagine what he can do
that and he's an adult that'd be Fant
you guys he attacks people with paint
cans and Micro Machines are you
available to be hired by James gun uh
please hire me I I need a job you're
welcome James and don't forget Rotten
Tomatoes helped you out that's it for on
the street comment right now and let us
know who's your favorite DCU superhero
of all time thanks for checking out on
the street I'm Mark Ellis we'll see you
next time right here at Rotten Tomatoes
thanks for checking this fit out head
over to rotten tomatoes.com for
everything in the world of movies TV and
in between in maricon 34th Street right
um you oh yeah I forgot I forgot how
this works Deacon I I wouldn't forget
Deacon that's my college masat seen a
lot of great cosplay over the years I
don't know that I've seen the Magical
Mystery Tour this is
great